bonjour bravo david un tu parles bien ça
me fait penser dans un pays lointain où
un président de la république a parlé à
son peuple il venait d'être élu il a dit
nous étions au bord du gouffre je suis
arrivé on va faire un grand pas en avant
donc moi tout a commencé autour de la
table de mon père qui s'appelait jean
françois chauvel qui était un grand
reporter au figaro
ses amis c'était joseph kessel pierre
chesnot refaire gilles caron
il racontait les histoires de leurs
aventures dans au biafra et partout donc
amender j'ai dit je voudrais le faire
serait faire la même chose que vous ils
vont regarder en disant tu ferais mieux
de finir tes études
mais au rythme de mes études j'aurais
passé mon bac à 40 ans donc c'était
peut-être pas la peine de continuer je
suis parti en douce en israël en 67 pour
couvrir le conflit
les photos étaient tellement mauvaise
que la seule qui était réussie c'est un
soldat israélien qui m'a pris mon
appareil photo et qui m'a pris en photo
donc j'ai au moins la preuve que j'étais
mais c'est tout donc quand tu rentrais à
france-soir faire un stage j'étais chez
carmen tessier le sap et les potins de
la colère et au deuxième reportage et
casser la gueule à polanski donc
lazareff m'a dit écoute tu t'ai demandé
de couvrir l'événement pas de le créer
donc ce qui serait bien c'est que tu
partes ailleurs donc location là c'était
l'année du têt c'était le vietnam style
j'avais un peu appris à faire des photos
je suis partie au vietnam et là j'ai eu
de la chance comme on dit pas pour les
vietnamiens mais pour moi c'était
l'offensive du têt la fameuse offensive
et donc j'ai commencé à faire des photos
et à partir avec les marines dans la
jungle et tout ça était très joyeux je
trouvais ça formidable d'être à plus de
300 km heure dans un hélicoptère de
sauter de courir partout et cetera
jusqu'au jour où il y avait un
prisonnier nord-vietnamiens qui était
sans doute un commandant qu'un cadre et
je suis passé devant lui avec les
appareils photo et j'ai trébuché et au
moment j'ai trébuché j'ai gueulé merde
donc il m'a dit ah vous êtes français
je ne vous le cacherai pas plus
longtemps et je l'aimais pas beaucoup il
était un des chefs communistes qui nous
tiraient dessus puis deux jours et
j'étais plutôt pote avec les américains
à l'époque et à il m'a dit je voudrais
vous raconter pourquoi je me compte je
me bats et il m'a parlé dans un parfait
français les mains attachées dans le dos
assez inconfortable et à la fin de son
discours où il m'expliquait son combat
sa lutte pour libérer le gâteau j'étais
moyennement convaincu mais ça commençait
à m'énerver puisqu'il y avait des
arguments et sa horde et mes copains
américain un peu moins juste dans leur
combat il m'a dit je vais être exécuté
si vous bougez pas ce qu'ils pourront
pas me trimbaler donc j'ai lu mais non
les américains ne font pas ça les
vietnamiens les suivis et amiens non
plus je suis allé voir le capitaine je
dis vous avez quand même pas le 6 et il
m'a dit pas si on bouge oui on veut pas
le travail et non pas le nourrir
après tout nous a tiré dessus et
effectivement il faut flinguer et j'ai
ressenti une immense solitude parce que
je n'étais pas d'accord avec ce ce cadre
sur la politique
enfin sur la manière de faire mon nom
qui s'appelle pierre schoendoerffer ça
n'arrangeait pas les choses il avait été
fait prisonnier à dien ben phu
donc j'avais histoire mais du coup je
n'arrivais plus à aimer les américains
de la même manière j'étais au milieu
en fait j'étais devenu journaliste un
joris est seule en fait parce qu'un
juriste c'est l'art de l'effacement
aussi difficile à dire aujourd'hui parce
qu'on voit que des gens risquent qui
montrent leur gueule mais normalement
c'est ça c'est l'art de les façons et
parce qu'on est là pour raconter le
message on peut raconter ce que font les
gens c'est il se confie à nous ils ont
confiance en nous j'avais été voir le
soldat le capitaine je l'avais engueuler
il m'a dit j'ai pas besoin de ta
sensiblerie j'ai besoin de toi de ton
talent pour raconter ce qui se passe tel
quel que ce soit pour contre nous et
j'ai besoin de ton talent et je veux que
tu racontes aux gens donc en fait on est
on est entre les deux donc je vais
passer quand même une
deux photos parce que j'ai complètement
oublié sais pas comment ça marche
l'autre côté voilà ça c'est le première
photo au vietnam
donc c'est à l'époque vous souhaitez ça
plutôt amusant voilà donc je faisais
plein de photos jeux patrouillaient dans
la jungle avec des gens là c'était une
réalité qui apparaissait de plus en plus
sévères des jeunes soldats et ans après
des civils brûlée au napalm et c'est
donc ma solitude augmenté j'ai fini par
me faire blesser moi aussi je suis
rentré à paris j'avais travaillé au à la
fois au vietnam et au cambodge et j'ai
pris un taxi
j'avais les plâtres des pansements
j'étais un peu bronzé parce qu'il fait
chaud et le chauffeur taxi me regarder
dans le rétroviseur jouets qui se
posaient des questions et il me dit
sport d'hiver et j'étais pas de bonne
humeur du tout donc je lui réponds pas
et quand même c'est irréfléchie et au
feu rouge il dit vous étiez où je vis
phnom penh fait absconnais pas cette
station c
donc j'ai vite compris qu'on en faisait
un travail important est que c'était
très utile mais en même temps il fallait
continuer parce que c'est les gens à
qu'on rencontre qui nous donne envie de
faire ce métier
malheureusement ça passe pas forcément
la barre à paris ou ailleurs mais je
voulais quand même vous faire comprendre
que c'est une passion que c'est un
métier une façon de livres et qu'on y
croit or aujourd'hui la presse est
menacée par les réseaux sociaux et c'est
très bien les réseaux sociaux mais il
faut quand même croire et écouter et
regarder les gens et ce professionnel
qui vont sur le terrain parce que il
confirme ce qu'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux ils sont là pour ils sont
normalement indépendant et voilà et en
même temps quelque fois on est très mal
perçu on est de moins en moins et mais
il ya un photographe qui s'appelle kevin
carter qui avait fait une photo d'un
vautour qui regardaient un petit enfant
africain qui était en train de mourir et
tout le monde l'a insultée en lisant ces
le vautour c'est toi c'est dégueulasse a
fait cette photo le la vraie histoire
derrière la photo et c'est ça qu'il faut
voir il photo ça c'est pas en une
seconde
il a vu effectivement le vautour était
plus loin et l'enfant en train de mourir
s'il avait été oublié à côté du camp il
s'est dit j'ai une photo là qui peut
faire symbolique et changer les choses
donc il a pris un téléobjectif pour
rapprocher le nouveau taux de l'enfant
il a fait cette photo est évidemment
après il a ramassé l'enfant il a mis à
la terre de la tente
il l'a donnée aux médecins ils ont sauvé
ils ont entretenu un rapport pendant
quelques années mais le photographe a
reçu tellement de l'aide d' insulte qui
s'est suicidé avant donc je veux dire il
faut quand même penser que il photos
qu'on voit comme par exemple celle ci
j'ai fait en libye
voilà c'est simple c'est it is cachent
cependant un bombardement mais pour la
faire ce n'est pas aussi simple
voilà ce qui s'est passé quand j'allais
la faire
ap
[Musique]
gregor beugnot
peut effectivement une photo c'est un
125e de seconde
mais avant et a pendant et après et on
est avec des gens et moi ce que j'essaye
de la raconter c'est leur histoire et je
suis un petit peu agacé par une certaine
presse qui se met plutôt en avant et on
n'entend pas trop parler l'histoire les
irakiens des syriens des pays signalent
ils font des plateaux enfin qu'on va pas
parler de ça trop longtemps mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne à un
temps plus long
bannir le mot scoop être j'entends
tellement souvent des gens dire j'étais
le premier à mossoul
on s'en fout je ne comprends pas c'est
pas une course à éviter le dernier quel
meilleur
on est là pour raconter l'histoire de
gens qui se confie à nous que ce soit en
radio en télévision en photo il faut
passer le temps trouver la bonne
distance les respecter les écouter parce
que les gens me disent vtt avec eux mais
c'est pas ce c'est pas eux
c'est nous ils sont mêmes gens que nous
donc je n'arrivais pas à trouver les
moyens j'avais l'impression que mes
photos servaient à rien et c'est
rappelle la question qu'on se pose
souvent à quoi bon faire toutes ces
photos de violence et un jour j'étais à
paris
les gens parlaient de plein de choses
sauf des conflits j'avais envie de dire
c'est formidable de vivre dans la paix
mais il faut quand même écouter ce qui
se passe si on connaît pas la guerre on
pourra jamais l'arrêter
on peut pas arrêter quelque chose qu'on
ne connaît pas donc j'ai eu cette idée
saugrenue de monter des images et de
foot la guerre à paris pour faire une
expo pour montrer aux gens
à quoi ça pouvait ressembler donc ça
donne ça on a un peu engueulé
que c'était anxiogène oui sans doute
c'est vrai que c'est dommage et il est
couché sur les droits de l'homme
monsieur l'avocat le morne s'est inscrit
en dessous
et donc voilà ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les gens s'y connaissent pas
ce qui se passe à l'étranger
il réagissait en voyant mes photos comme
celle là en me disant mais c'est
terrible c'est pas vrai gentil bata pas
écouter la radio ce matin sinon de les
connaître et à côté il y avait la vraie
photo des tchétchènes mort sur la place
minute k à grozny exane s'est accroché
mais pourquoi ce serait bien à grozny ce
qu'on voit pas aussi ils ont une place
qu'ils aiment et donc voilà donc j'ai
essayé de transporter le le sujet à
paris pour faire comprendre que c'était
bien de s'amuser mais qu'il fallait
aussi écouter les journalistes qui font
leur travail
donc le reportage que j'ai fait
récemment c'était en au sol
donc ça c'est j'y retourne c'est un
reportage en cours et c'est pareil les
qui peut demander ce que les français
s'intéressent à nous est ce que vous
allez faire quelque chose pour nous ce
sont des jeunes gens comme vous pouvez
voir ils ont d'ailleurs les mêmes
coiffure dans certains endroits
à paris les six bizarre parce que
l'information elle circule dans l'autre
sens aussi une fois j'ai un paillis
iñaki lisait l'orient le jour à beyrouth
sur pleine guerre ils étaient couverts
de poussière avec des tartes ou cher et
il y avait la saq d'oueds elle questeur
oui à la tribune qui était tombé sur des
spectateurs d'un match de foot et qui
avait tué 40 personnes et il a baissé le
journal il m'a dit mais vous êtes des
sauvages et vous avez vous avait pas
d'armes
il me dit 40 morts sans armes mais il
faut venir nous aider
donc ça c'est à mossoul c'est la
division doré là qui sont à la tête de
l'offensive donc je veux juste montrer
un dernier reportage
ils se battent maison par maison c'est
compliqué me saoule pas ce que vous avez
à faire des gens qui n'ont pas envie de
survivre
vous avez entre 2000 et 3000 ça c'est un
peu comme les magnifier le chef de la
police le chef des manifestants
il ya entre 2000 et 3000 kamikaze en
fait qu'ils tiennent en otage quatre
cent mille civils
donc c'est la première fois que je suis
face à à des gens qui n'ont pas envie de
survivre et qui se bat jusqu'au bout
là on se prit le voiture une voiture
kamikaze qui a foncé sur notre pourvoi
petit détail en passant le photographe
qui tourne le dos à la photo c'est mon
fils qui apprend le métier je lui ai dit
c'est dans l'autre sens un tour
mais ça rentre ça rentre alors ça c'est
l'hôpital qui est un qui l'aurait du
front j'ai demandé au capitaine qui
était en train de noter quelque chose
sur le sac qui contenait un soldat
est-ce que tu m'aies son nom il m'a dit
non je ne connais pas son nom parce
qu'il est très abîmé je mets un héros
irakiens sont des gens qui croient à ce
qu'ils font donc moi j'essaye de
transmettre ça des gens dans le monde
entier pour leur faire comprendre que si
on voit tous ces réfugiés arrivés pour
moi ça me fait penser aux réfugiés de la
de 1940 c'est pas eux c'est nous c'est
la même chose donc vous faire attention
faut les écouter
voilà ça c'est un médecin américain qui
a demandé à soigner ses enfants qu a
pris une balle dans la tête ils arrosent
moi et à ma vie j'ai fait remarquer que
l'enfant était au soleil matches battu
dans la cub
donc j'ai posé les appareils photo les
pompes venger de la mission qui m'avait
confié j'ai vu piquer sa couverture
toute neuve et j'ai posé l'enfant dessus
l'enfant s'en est sorti à la balle a
ricoché sur le front en fait la pab
touché la boîte crânienne
j'ai évidemment suivi l'enfant à
l'hôpital pour voir comment ça se
passait et en fait là j'ai été plus
photographe
j'étais en train de parler à ses enfants
a essayé de le calmer
en fait il me faisait penser à mon
dernier fils qui a des cauchemars
quelquefois et donc ils pleurent et
j'essaie de le calmer
sauf que là le problème le cauchemar à
mossoul sépare dont les réveiller mais
est encore que le soldat
a repris l'enfant pour la mère à
l'hôpital parce que l'ambulance était
arrivé je me suis levé j'ai décidé de
faire cette photo parce que je pensais
que comme kevin carter s'était plus
important de faire la photo a demandé
quand je pouvais quand je n'avais plus
besoin que j'intervienne parce qu'elle
symbolise est ce que ces gens sont en
train de souffrir
rien en passant j'avais l'impression
qu'il venait de naître ressemble à
l'enfance et la guerre qu'à gauche et
lui mais il ya quelque chose de bizarre
dans cette photo est plus loin dans sa
ces appareils photos de mon fils il a eu
beau se retourner un morceau de la bombe
il ya un bousier ces appareils mais ce
qui est terrible c'est que ces gens ils
nous appellent et nous disent merci
d'être là
vous êtes venu de votre confort enfin
que les spams ont la partie mais vous
êtes connus vous êtes venu de votre
confort en france pour raconter notre
histoire est vraiment pour conclure si
j'essaye de vous dire que c'est une
passion et qu'on y croit alors je sais
qu'on n'aime plus tellement la presse
aujourd'hui
mais il ya quand même une bande de deux
photographes de caméraman de journaliste
écrit et de gens et aux radios qui sont
qui parcourent ces endroits et qui
croient et un moment donné il ya un
homme qui est venu me voir et qui m'a
dit mon fils est gravement blessé il
voudrait vous parlez donc il y avait un
petit garçon de huit ans et qui m'a
pointé du doigt et qui m'a parlé comme
ça en arabe
j'ai fait traduire après et il m'a dit
je te préviens si tu racontes pas notre
histoire moi je vais tout dire à dieu
parce que vous avez fait donc voilà je
préfère l'arrêt parfait
[Applaudissements]